hi there welcome back to another gadget
lab I am Michael colori I am America
Baldwin so Robbie in addition to all the
other amazing and exciting companies it
covers also reports on Intel which I
made a big announcement at the All
Things D conference down on the gonna do
my hometown oh nice yeah they're diving
dive in the media Erik huggers hopped on
stage and talked about Intel's new
insane it's kind of insane for them to
be jumping into this market so they're
going to be creating a set-top box which
is ok everyone else set-top box but
they're also going to be delivering all
the content to that box so Intel is
going to turn into a comcast the dish
network Time Warner there they're making
deals with Disney and A&E and TNG and
all these other companies so that you
have one box to rule them all it'll
still have apps you'll still have your
netflix and all that stuff so this
sounds insane it does it's you know I've
had a DVR that I rent from like Comcast
you know for six dollars a month for the
last I don't know 12 years or something
like that and they're going to replace
that they're going to replay they want
to replace everything replace your cable
box your Roku or Apple TV all that will
be taken care of by one magical Intel
box that we don't know anything about
other than that they're making it we
don't a price we don't have a launch
date other than 2013 and it's going to
have all that this but it'll be a
subscription thing right like all pay
them eighty dollars a month to get all
my television over that instead of
paying you know sixty bucks to comcast
at fifteen bucks to Netflix yeah so you
well you would still have net you can
still get netflix and amazon and all
those so you still have to pay those
guys in the who lose okay but your cable
cable content will be from would be from
intel and they're sort of they have like
to sort of things that they say are
going to get you onto one is it's going
to blow your mind the interface no they
didn't say blow your mind but they're
really talking up the interface what are
they going to do like new software there
there's they're like the TV you know the
guide listings look at spreadsheet
they're totally changing that we're
changing at all
which we don't know how horns discovery
call me skeptical yeah yeah without
seeing something it's always it's pretty
easy to be skeptical yeah and also there
they touched on air touched our huggers
touched a little bit on more reasonable
bundles right now then you by Comcast or
when you get Dish you you get a bundle
you get premium package bundle you get
the mid-level bundle you get like the
sports bundle right you end up paying
for all these channels you don't really
want right um yeah like I pay like a
dollar 11 a month for you know like the
tennis channel yeah I never watch no one
watches no there are people out there
I'm sure three people watching so
they'll they'll have the opportunity to
buy like a tennis package say or like
maybe yeah you know it's it you know and
still it's all kind up in the air and
but they're just talking about more
reasonable because okay if they tried to
go out and get a la carte like just tell
everybody they wanted all a carte
options for their viewers that no one
would sign a deal with them that's just
kind of a given in the end he mean on
the content and yes they are they
wouldn't get the channel's the property
sign up no one no matter how bad
consumers not no notnot that's probably
not gonna happen for a long time I think
it's going to happen eventually but
right now those content creators are not
down with the sort of ala carte thing so
I think the expectation from what I'm
reading right now is that it's going to
be around the same money that you're
paying now but you get more of what you
want and less of what you don't for the
same money yes and the amazing you I
that we don't know anything about that
that Intel is going to build from
scratch yes having no track record of
having built an awesome you I yes okay
well we'll see it what happens if it's
gonna happen when in the fall maybe
sometime in 2013 so january thirty first
1159 p.m. 2013 I'm sorry December 31st I
yo December 31st 1159 p.m. 2013 they
could still deliver it and deliver it on
time ok so we'll see big things from
Intel shaking up the cable industry
maybe maybe thanks Robbie thank you and
we're going to bring on Christina now to
tell us about some map
news hi Christina hello Michael so
earlier this week there was some
increase in the speculation that Apple
is working on a wearable computer maybe
a SmartWatch yes maybe a little
something goes in your wrist arounds iOS
mm-hmm that is not a tiny little ipod
right yeah tell us about that yeah so
let's see so New York Times Wall Street
Journal Bloomberg all had separate
reports confirming that Apple has a
large team of about a hundred people as
the latest working on this wearable
project it's likely to be some sort of
smart watch it on your wrist and could
have curved glass display because Apple
has been investing a lot in curved glass
like a curse touch screen mmhmm yeah
yeah and then you know it run iOS and
interface with your iOS apps on your
iphone or ipad maybe have some dedicated
ones that are just you know just
designed for you know being used on the
wrist um Siri oh so you can talk to the
wall yeah talk to you yeah secret agent
that makes sense yeah now before this
this latest round of reports from
anonymous sources you did your own story
about this last week or the week before
i should say which you know basically
looks into should Apple work on this are
they possibly working on this tell us a
little bit about you know but first of
all do you think this is something
that's coming from them yeah and if so
what would it what would it look like a
slide from what you've what you've
already said yeah so I mean I definitely
think that Apple does have resources
investigating investigating this the
wearable space is kind of the next
frontier in mobile technology so it
would be prudent of Apple to be involved
in that as for what it looks like i have
no no no yeah but they do have to get
into it yet and there's a lot of places
they have to get into right like they
have to get into tvs eventually but just
because there's a speculation right now
it doesn't mean that we're gonna see
something in six months right yeah it
could be two or three years from now or
initely or further yeah yeah chi luck
with the iPad like you know the ipad
came out the said
working on this for decades all right so
maybe not a watch at the next event
coming up in March or April but
something but probably not a watch yeah
watch well thank you for that and you
can continue to read all Kristina's
Apple coverage and everything else we
cover on the gadget lab and until next
week we will see you later